NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL ROLE.
ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA BAKER. BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE COLLIER O. CALDERON
CARILLO SERVAN SAYS CHAU. CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU. CHOI KANSEN
CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DAHLE DALY. EGGMAN
FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER KALRA.
GALLAGHER DOES KILEY. LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON OWN. LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA. REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO. SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON. WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
PLEASE STAND FOR TODAY'S A
VOCATION WHICH WILL BE DELIVERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
.
LIBBY WHEN PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION.
HAPPINESS HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS
FINDING BALANCE IN LIFE.
BALANCE BETWEEN WORK AND PLAY.
BETWEEN RESTON ACTIVITY.
PEACE OF MIND IN FULFILLMENT.
HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED AS LIVING
WITH THE FEELING THAT OUR WORK
AND PLAY AND ARRESTED ACTIVITY.
BECOME ONE AND THE SAME.
I'VE LONG APPRECIATED THIS QUOTE
BY THE NOVELIST JAMES MICHENER
WHO SAID.
THE MASTER IN THE ART OF LIVING
MAKES LITTLE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
WORK AND PLAY. BETWEEN LABOR AND
LEISURE BETWEEN THEIR MIND IN
THEIR BODY.
BETWEEN INFORMATION AND
RECREATION.
BETWEEN LOVE AND RELIGION.
THE MASTER OF THE ART OF LIVING
HARDLY KNOWS WHICH IS WHICH.
HE SIMPLY PURSUE THEIR VISION OF
EXCELLENCE AT WHATEVER THEY DO.
LEAVING OTHERS TO DECIDE WHETHER
IT IS WORKING OR PLAYING.
IF SUCH A PERSON. THEY ARE
ALWAYS DOING BOTH.
THIS PAST TUESDAY WE WELCOMED
THE SPIRITUAL TEACHER AN
AMBASSADOR FOR WORLD PEACE
SHE SHE RAVISHANKAR TO OUR STATE
CAPITOL.
SHE SHE HAS ALSO COMMENTED ON
THIS NEED DIVINE BALANCE IN ONE
US IN OUR LIVES.
HE IS SAID.
ACTIVITY IN REST ARE TOO VITAL
ASPECTS OF LIFE.
YOU FIND A BALANCE IN THEM IS A
SKILL IN ITSELF.
WISDOM IS KNOWING WHEN TO HAVE
BREAST
AND WHEN DO HAVE ACTIVITY.
AND HOW MUCH.
THE BEACH IT AND TO HAVE.
BINDING THEM IN EACH OTHER
ACTIVITY IN REST INVESTED
ACTIVITY. IS THE ULTIMATE
FREEDOM.
THIS ALL CONTINUE TO SEEK SUCH
BALANCE IN ONE US IN OUR LIVES.
NOW MONIQUE. WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
I INVITE YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE WHICH WILL
BE LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL.
ATTENTION TO THE COLORS
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE PRIOR.
ON HAITIAN.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY APRIL FIFTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE A. M. ON A
LAURA FRIEDMAN AS.
EAGER PRO TEM OF THE ASTRONAUTS
ASIA MISTER DALY SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTIONS AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IAN CALDERON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELISSA MELENDEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KEVIN MULLIN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILL QUIRK
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED HERE MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW THE SPEAKER
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMOND.
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. AND ALLOW
SPEAKER RENDON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BLOOM MAYES MEDINA AND FRAZIER
TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
ON THE FOLLOWING BILLS A. B.
NINETEEN ELEVEN LACKEY TO ALLOW
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE THE BILL FOR THEIR APRIL.
TWENTY SIXTH HEARING PENNY RE
REFER OFTEN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND AB THIRTY THIRTY
W. ARROW TO ALLOW THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE. TO NOTICE
THE BILL FOR THEIR APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH HEARING PENDING RE
REFERRAL FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX AND WITHDRAW AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX STEINORTH
FROM THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
ORDER THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO WITHDRAW AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
TWO LEVINE. FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
ORDERED THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILED THE BILL IS NO
LONGER FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MINUTES BIGGER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE OF AB SEVENTEEN FORD.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY DAILY FROM
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE GALLAGHER FROM THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. AND AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN QUIRK
SILVA FROM THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL IN THE ORDER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND FINALLY PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR A.
B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY FIVE MAYES
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CLERK WILL KNOW
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO SPEAKER
RENDON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ON MONDAY AFTERNOON IT WAS MY
HONOR TO ADMINISTER THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO.
OR TO KNOW THE NEWEST ASSEMBLY
MEMBER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SYDNEY COME LAGER
DOT. MANY OF YOU WERE ON HAND
FOR THAT.
CEREMONY AND A LOT OF YOU OF
TAKING YOUR TIME TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES WE ALL KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO START MID
STREAM PARTICULARLY DURING THE
SECOND YEAR OF A TWO YEAR.
SESSION THAT CERTAINLY ADDS A
DEGREE OF DIFFICULTY BUT SHE'S
SHE'S UP TO THE TASK.
SO I WANNA AND HOPE THAT YOU ALL
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR NEW
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES AND I
KNOW THAT HELD OFF FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND FRIENDSHIP. TO HER
.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU TODAY.
UNIQUE LOVE IT.
SHE WAS VOTED BEST A BREAKOUT
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR FOR THE
AMERICAN NINJA WARRIOR.
UNIQUE PLACE.
MEMBERS ARE NOT DONE YET.
JUDY PLACED A HISTORIC FIRST
AMONG WOMEN.
AND THE LOS ANGELES CITY
QUALIFIER FOR THE AMERICAN NINJA
WARRIOR TV SHOW.
SETTING AN EXAMPLE FOR WOMEN
EVERYWHERE WHO SEEK TO ACHIEVE
THEIR ATHLETIC DREAMS.
MOST RECENTLY.
VINIK COMPLETED ON TEAM FROST
Y..
ONE THE NEW AMERICAN NINJA
LAWYER SHOW NINJA VERSES NAY
JOB.
SURMOUNTING OBSTACLES LIKE BILL
POLL GRASP HER THE TICK TOCK.
AND THE SPIN CYCLE.
A WOMAN OF FAITH.
WE DO NEED IS A POSITIVE OLE
MODEL FOR HER HUSBAND. HER
CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND FOR ALL WHO STRIVE TO REACH
THEIR HIGHEST POTENTIAL.
TO QUOTE THE SHOW.
JONI MENIFEE.
WE DON'T LIKE IT WE LOVE IT.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING.
UNIQUE LOVE YOU.
TWO THE CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL
HERE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
AND ALSO I CHALLENGE YOU TO JOIN
US.
UPON ADJOURNMENT. FOR A
LEGISLATIVE LIKE SAW. ON THE
SELECTED WAR ROTONDO.
MEMBERS.
JOIN A CLUB.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
GOOD MORNING.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME MISS
CAMPBELL'S CLASS FROM CEDAR
GROVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLING COULD
BE NOT. IN MY DISTRICT THEY'VE
COME A LONG WAY UP TO SACRAMENTO
TODAY TO TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
AND LEARN ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE. AND OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE PLEASE GIVE A
WARM WELCOME TO THE STUDENTS.
OF CEDAR GLOW GROVE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
WHILE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMOND YOUR
RECOGNIZE FROM.
ESTHER MULLINS DEATHS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS.
CONTINUING WITH.
THIS MORNING'S THEME.
OF WOMEN LEADERS OF SPORTS IT'S
AN HONOR FOR ME TO MAKE A VERY
SPECIAL. INTRODUCTION HERE ON
THE ASSEMBLY.
A FEW MONTHS AGO WE PRESENTED A
RESOLUTION THAT TALKED ABOUT
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GIRLS AND WOMEN IN SPORTS.
AND BREAKING THE GLASS CEILING
TODAY I'M HONORED TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU. THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN CEO OF A MAJOR
SPORTS FRANCHISE IN THE NATIONAL
BASKETBALL ASSOCIATION CYNTHIA
MARSHALL WHO IS HERE TODAY.
THEN WHILE HER KEYS IS AN OUT OF
CALIFORNIA TEAM THAT WE CANNOT
ROUTE FOR.
SHE IS PART OF TEAM CALIFORNIA.
SHE HAILS FROM RICHMOND.
SHE IS A MIGHTY EAGLE FROM
KENNEDY HIGH SCHOOL. OVERCOMING
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS FROM HOUSING
PROJECTS TO LEADING GRAY
PROGRAMS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND
FOR DIVERSITY THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
SHE HAS BEEN A GREAT LEADER WHO
ARE READY IN JUST A FEW WEEKS
HAS CHANGED THE CULTURE OF THE
ORGANIZATION HER TEAM IS THE
DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND SHE HAS CHANGED THE CULTURE
MAKING KEY HIRES FOR WOMEN TO
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO LEAD FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO BE A CHANCE
TO HAVE THE CHANCE. TO LEAD IN
THE COMMUNITY WE'RE SO HONORED
FOR WHAT SHE HAS DONE IT WILL
CONTINUE TO DO TO ADDRESS ISSUES
LIKE SEXUAL HARASSMENT. TO
ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE WORKPLACE
DIVERSITY AND HER COMMITMENT TO
PLAYER DEVELOPMENT IN SUPPORTING
YOUTH IT'S IS BROUGHT TO US BY
SOMEONE IN OUR SACRAMENTO.
CAPITAL COMMUNITY PHYLLIS
MARSHALL WHO MANY OF YOU KNOW IS
THE CHIEF LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
FOR LA COUNTY A PLEASE ONCE
AGAIN PUT YOUR HANDS TOGETHER
FOR OUR NEW C. E. O.. CYNTHIA
MARSHALL MIGHTY
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DILY FILE.
MOVING TO SECOND READING MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE WITH
LEMONS THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTY ONE SIXTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS RIGHT BY THE
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY TWENTY WITH AMENDMENTS.
TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE AT THE
MOMENT THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY TWO SEVENTEEN NINETY
NINE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED TWENTY
TWENTY NINE. NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY
EIGHTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS MADE BY FORTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS. TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY SIX AT THE MOMENT TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE EIGHTEEN OH
FIVE NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE
NINETEEN SIXTY TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO THOUSAND.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
FORTY SIX TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT POINT TWO SEVENTY POINT
TWO EIGHTY ONE TWENTY THREE
NINETY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
TWO. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY NINE
TWENTY FOUR NINETY TWENTY FIVE
SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FIVE FORTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY FOUR. TWENTY SIX
FORTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
FIVE TWENTY A ONE TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT. TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE NINETY THIRTY FORTY
THREE THIRTY ONE CITY THREE
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINETY SEVEN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TEN
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX POINT FIVE FORTY NINE
TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX. POINT
NINE SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND AND
TWO NINETEEN TWELVE THE MEMONS
THIRTY FORTY FIVE. NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
THREE FIVE SIXTY SIX WITH THE
MOMENTS TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY NINE
OF THE MOMENTS. THIRTY TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOURTH AMENDMENT'S THIRTY
FORTY WITH AMENDMENTS TO A
REPLAY THROUGH THAT DEMONSTRATES
IT EIGHTEEN OF THE MOMENTS
TWENTY NINE THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS MADE RECENT FIVE
MINUTES AND TWENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
HE MEMBERS RETURNING NOW TO
ITEMS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ITEMS THE SEVENTY FOUR THROUGH
SEVENTY SEVEN.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT THROUGH
EIGHTY PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM EIGHTY ONE AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MADAM CLERK SHE REACHED THE
ITEM.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
REMEMBER MURATSUCHI.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SUJI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ABC.
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE WHICH ALLOWS
KITTENS TO BE MADE IMMEDIATELY
AVAILABLE TO NONPROFIT RESCUE
GROUPS.
A PULL FROM A SHELTER BANANAS
BEFORE YOU TODAY WILL ALSO
INCLUDE PUPPIES TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR RESCUE
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
MEMBERS BE ADOPTED IN THE BILL
THEY GO OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
SEEING NO DEBATER DISCUSSION
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
.
MANY QUICKLY IS CLOSE THE ROLE A
TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY KNOWS YOU'RE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
ITEM EIGHTY TO PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO OH OH ONE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE BY SOME A
MEMBER REYES AND I
WHEN THE CHILD CARE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWO THOUSAND ONE STANDARDIZES
ALLIANCE AND CODIFIES DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME EDUCATION NETWORK
CONTRACTORS AND PROVIDERS. THAT
OFFER A PROMISING PRACTICE MODEL
FOR THE STATE TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF FAMILY CHILDCARE
OPTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAW LACKS CONSISTENT
ADMINISTRATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE NETWORKS
SO TOOLS USED TO MAKE QUALITY
ASSESSMENT MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE TO FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOME SETTINGS.
AB TWO THOUSAND ONE TAKES THE
FIRST STEP IN PROVIDING FOR
CONSISTENCY IN IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE PROGRAMS STATEWIDE AS A
VALUABLE TOOL. AS A ROOF FORWARD
IN PROVIDING THE HIGHEST QUALITY
OF CHILDCARE OPTIONS FOR
FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY DEVOTES EYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS THIRTEEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM S. EIGHTY SIX A.
B. EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE BY SOME
THE MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THINK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT ONE IN FIVE WOMEN
SUFFERS FROM MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS. THESE
DISORDERS CAN INCLUDE ANXIETY
DEPRESSION OR EVEN POST PARTUM
PSYCHOSIS
AND CAN AFFECT WOMEN DURING
PREGNANCY IN WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR AFTER GIVING BIRTH AMONG
MOTHERS AND POVERTY NEARLY FIFTY
PERCENT WILL BE AFFECTED BY ONE.
OR MORE MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER MANY STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT TOOLS AND RESOURCES
TO SCREEN OR TREAT WOMEN.
I FROM MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
IS SEVERELY LACKING AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE WILL REQUIRE THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO APPLY FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING
THOSE FUNDS ASSOCIATED.
TWENTY SIXTEEN BRINGING
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION OUT OF THE
SHADOWS ACT.
BY TWO JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH MUST
NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE OF ITS
PLANS FOR UTILIZING THESE FUNDS
IF THEY ARE AWARDED.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE WRONG. MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT MADAME
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD AND
ACTUALLY THE FAMILY LAW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AMOUNT SPEAKER REMEMBERS AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT WOULD
PROVIDE GUIDANCE IN THE RARE
SITUATION IN WHICH A JUST
PATIENT ALL CARRIER. EXPERIENCES
A PROCESS CALLED SUPER FEET
HAITIAN AND GIVES BIRTH TO HER
OWN BIOLOGICAL CHILD AT THE SAME
TIME IS GIVING BIRTH TO THE BABY
OF AN INTENDED COUPLE. WHILE
THIS SITUATION IS WHERE THE
WASHINGTON POST REPORTER LAST
YEAR ABOUT THIS VERY SITUATION
OCCURRING RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAW IS SILENT ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF THIS HAPPENING
WITHIN THE REALM OF ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION AGREEMENTS.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT ASSISTED PUT
REPRODUCTION AGREEMENTS CONTAIN
A DISCLOSURE PROVISION. STATING
THAT ANY CHILD CONCEIVED BY THE
JUST ISSUED ALL CARRIER THROUGH
SEXUAL INTERCOURSE IS THE TRIAL
OF THE JUST THEY SHOULD ALL
CARRIER. I RESPECTFULY ASK YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SEE NO DEBATE NOR
DISCUSSION THAT OCCURRED PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY EXCUSE ME PARDON
ME MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ THE
ITEM. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
FORTY THREE BY SOME A MEMBER LOW
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY UNLAWFUL
BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THANK YOU THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE WHICH DOES ONE THING AND
ONE THING ONLY. IT CODIFIES
EXISTING COURT DECISIONS AND
CLARIFIES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMER FRAUD LAWS. BAR THE
LONG DISCREDITED IN HARMFUL
PRACTICE OF CONVERSION THERAPY.
IT'S FALSELY PROMISES TO BE ABLE
A CHANGE ONE'S SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY.
THE BILL IS EXPRESS.
IN ITS TERMS OF LIMITING THE
PRACTICE OF CONVERSION THERAPY
AS A COMMERCIAL SERVICE IN
EXCHANGE FOR MONETARY
COMPENSATION. DOES NOT APPLY.
TO THE SALE OF BOOKS.
OR ANY OTHER KINDS OF GOODS IT
DOES NOT PREVENT ANYONE FROM
SPEAKING OR WRITING ON THE
SUBJECT. OF CONVERSION THERAPY
IN ANY FORM WITH RESPECT I ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER OUR QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR WITHOUT OBJECTION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OF MYSTERY
AUTHOR OR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
AS THERE'S A LOT OF US OPINIONS
SWIRLING IN A LOT OF THINGS
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
ESPECIALLY.
IN SOMETHING THAT I AM
CONNECTED TO THAT WOULD BE THE
FAITH COMMUNITY.
YOUR BILL HOW DOES THAT IMPACT
OF THE FAITH COMMUNITY HOW DOES
IT IMPACT CHURCHES AND HOW WOULD
IT IMPACT THE CURRENT PRACTICES
THAT THEY DO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS
DOES NOT A IMPACT OF WITH
RESPECT TO FREEDOM OF SPEECH OR
FREEDOM OF RELIGION. OF THIS IS
VERY NARROW IN SCOPE UNDER THEIR
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT
WHICH IS THAT OF A FINANCES
TRANSACTION.
SO IF YOU ARE IN A CHURCH AND
THEY STILL WOULD LIKE TO PREACH
WHATEVER THE BELIEVES MIGHT BE.
OF THAT IS STILL LEGAL AND
ALLOWED UNDER THE LAW A BUT ONE
CANNOT BE ADVERTISE WITH THE
TRANSACTION TO MAKE A PROFIT.
THIS NOTION THAT YOU CAN BE
CHANGED.
WITH RESPECT TO SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND SEXUAL IDENTITY
SO TO BE VERY CLEAR THIS IS VERY
NARROW IN SCOPE UNDER THIS
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT.
IS THAT OF A CONSUMER
TRANSACTION.
YOU CAN STILL TALK ABOUT THAT
BELIEVES OF WHATEVER THE FREEDOM
OF RELIGION MIGHT BE.
AND THAT IS STILL POSSIBLE IN
FACT IT IS ALSO STILL POSSIBLE
FOR WITHIN THE CONFINES OF A
CHURCH TO TALK ABOUT THAT THEY
CAN CHANGE YOU. SO LONG AS THAT
THERE IS NOT A FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OUT WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR I I
BELIEVE THAT IF PASSED AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR I'D THAT
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD BE. A
OVERTURNED INDEED BY A HIGHER
COURT ARE ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND REGARDS TO
THE FREEDOM OF RELIGION. FREEDOM
OF SPEECH WHERE THE PRESS AND
THE RIGHT TO FREELY ASSEMBLE.
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN THAT
CONVERSION THERAPY IS
INEFFECTIVE AND DAMAGING.
SCIENCE IN FACT SHOW THAT BEING
LGBT Q. IS NOT A DISEASE OR
DISORDER OR AN ILLNESS. ARE LGBT
Q..
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECTED TO FRAUDULENT
PRACTICES WHICH COULD POSE
CRITICAL HEALTH RISKS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
RISING I THINK IS THE ONLY
LICENSED CLINICAL.
PRACTITIONER IN THIS HOUSE I
WILL JUST SAY THAT THIS LIKE A
PRACTICE THAT HAS LONG BEEN
DISCREDITED. NOBODY GOES TO A
PROFESSIONAL THERAPIST I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO GET CHANGE FROM
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
FRAUDULENT SHOULD NOT BE
OCCURRING IT IS DAMAGING TO
PEOPLE AND FOR THOSE WHO STILL
HAVE WORD ABOUT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT YOU CAN STILL
TRY TO PRAY THE GAY AWAY IF
YOU'D LIKE. UP BUT BUT WE HASN'T
PROVED TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
CERTAINLY IF YOU GO SEE CA
LICENSED PERSON WHO IS LICENSED
UNDER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE. PSYCHOTHERAPY TREATMENT
ADVERTISE IT YOU CAN CHANGE
SEVENTY SEXUAL ORIENTATION IS
SIMPLY THAT FRAUDULENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I LARGE
FAITH BASED COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT AND AGAIN SOME THE
CONCERNS OVER REITERATED FOR THE
AREA OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
MORE SPECIFICALLY IN AREAS OF
LITERATURE
SO SO NUMBER IF YOU CAN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. WITHOUT OBJECTIVELY DO
LIKE TO DO THAT NOW OR IN YOUR
CLOTHES I'M JUST CLARIFICATION
OF WHAT THE QUESTION WAS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
UP IN THE AREA OF THE LITERATURE
IN THE AREA OF BOOKS HOUSE OF
IMPACT.
FOR SOME OF.
I WILL ASK YOU TO ADDRESS THAT
IN YOUR CLOTHING RATHER THAN NOW
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE WOULD
MAKE CLEAR THAT CLAIMING TO BE
ABLE TO CHANGE A PERSON'S SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
OR GENDER IDENTITY AND EXCHANGE
FOR PAYMENT IS A FRAUDULENT
BUSINESS PRACTICE.
THAT MISLEADS CONSUMERS AND
EXPOSES LGBT PEOPLE.
TO DAMAGING PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT LGBT IS
PART OF THE NATURAL SPECTRUM OF
HUMAN IDENTITY.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG OR BROKEN
WITH THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS BANNED
CONVERSION THERAPY IS A PRACTICE
FOR MINORS
IT IS STILL BEING PRACTICED ON
ADULTS EVEN THOUGH CONTEMPORARY
SCIENCE RECOGNIZES THAT LGBT IS
PART OF THE NATURAL SPECTRUM OF
HUMAN IDENTITY? AND IS NOT A
DISEASE DISORDER OR ILLNESS.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE THAT OF A CONSUMER
SUFFERS DAMAGES AS A RESULT OF
THESE HARMFUL PRACTICES THEN THE
CONSUMER COULD BRING AN ACTION
TO RECOVER THOSE DAMAGES.
ACCORDINGLY AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE DOES NOT TOUCH ON FREEDOM
OF SPEECH OR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
BECAUSE IT SIMPLY PUTS
CONVERSION THERAPY. ON THE SAME
LEVEL AS OTHER FRAUDULENT
SERVICES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES KNOW WHAT
TO BE ABLE TO PROFIT FROM THEM.
A CONVERSION THERAPY IS A
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY THAT HAS NO
SCIENTIFIC BASIS.
I AM THINKING ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
AND AND ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE.
MADE TIMES ARE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
MISLED BY THINGS THAT THEY HEAR
THAT THEY THINK I MIGHT BE TRUER
MIGHT BE ACCURATE IN THIS YEAR I
INTRODUCED A BILL. THAT WOULD
HELP US SUPPORT LGBT STUDENTS
TO HELP THEM NOT BE IMPACTED BY
BULLYING OR IMPACTED BY THINGS
THAT MIGHT CAUSE HARM TO THEM. I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR RUSTED
THE CLEAR THAT THIS IS A
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY AND THAT
THERE ARE PENALTIES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD PROFIT OFF OF IT. AND
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE I THINK AND I I
THINK THE REASON WHY.
IT'S A DIFFICULT ISSUE IS
BECAUSE IT GOES TO THE VERY.
.
CENTER OF PEOPLE'S IDENTITY.
AND AND WHO THEY ARE WHO THEY
BELIEVE THEY ARE.
.
AND SO I AM VERY MUCH HEARD MY
COLLEAGUE ACTUALLY OTHERS.
IN IN COMMITTEE WHEN THE WHEN
THE BILL WAS UP.
AND DEFTLY HEARD.
FROM HIM THE HURT AND YOU KNOW
THE.
THE OSTRACIZE ASIAN THAT MANY
FEEL. MANY IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY
OF FELT. BECAUSE OF.
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED ESPECIALLY AS BEING A
YOUNG PERSON AND.
AND ON AND STRUGGLING WITH
ISSUES OF OF IDENTITY.
AND SO I VERY MUCH FEAR THAT I
SEE IN A.
NO THAT THAT'S THE MOTIVATION.
BEHIND YOUR BILL.
BUT I THINK THE THING THAT.
THAT I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER YOU AS HE'S MOVING
FORWARD HIS BILL IS.
IS CONSIDERING THE VERY GENUINE
I THINK LEGITIMATE EXPERIENCE OF
PEOPLE WHO WHO TESTIFIED IN THAT
COMMITTEE.
AND THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
THAT HELP THEM.
AND THAT WORK FOR THEM.
I'M I BELIEVE THESE PEOPLE WERE
VERY I MEAN.
HEARING THAT TESTIMONY WAS VERY
POWERFUL AS WELL.
AND AND THAT.
FREEDOM IF IT MEAN SOMETHING IT
MEANS IT MEANS AND.
THE BILL WOULD BE FREE TO BE WHO
YOU ARE.
TOM AND I THINK IT ALSO MUST
ALSO MEAN.
FREEDOM TO BE WHO YOU WANT TO
BE.
AND I THINK FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED AND HAVE HAVE COME
FORWARD DOOR AS THIS BILL IS
MOVE FORWARD.
.
THEY WOULD PROBABLY TELL YOU
THAT THIS IS WHO THEY ARE.
AND.
I THINK WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
THAT EXPERIENCE IT MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT.
FROM OTHER PEOPLE'S EXPERIENCE
RIGHT.
WHERE IT'S BEEN VERY HURTFUL
IT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
DAMAGING BUT FOR THOSE PEOPLE I
THINK WE HAVE TO CONSIDER THAT
LIVING IN A FREE SOCIETY IS IS
THE FREEDOM?
THE PEOPLE THAT DO THINGS THAT
MAYBE WE THINK ARE NOT THE BEST.
MAYBE THAT WE THINK ARE HER
FULLER DAMAGES I THINK THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE LEGITIMATE EXPERIENCE OF
PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE?
GONE THROUGH CONVERSION THERAPY
AND HAVE SET HAVES AND HAVES.
AT HAVE SAID THAT THIS WAS A
GOOD THING FOR THEM THE OTHER
THING I THINK WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER IS.
IS POTENTIALLY APPLICATION FOR
FOR THE FAITH COMMUNITY.
.
AND I THINK MAYBE THIS BEARS A
LITTLE BIT OF EXPLANATION IS.
CHRISTIANS DO BELIEVE AND.
THEY BELIEVE IN SPIRITUAL
TRANSFORMATION.
CHRISTIANS BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
ALL.
SINNERS
WE WE ALL EQUALLY FALLS SHORT OF
THE GLORY OF GOD.
NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT CHRIST DID
ON THE CROSS.
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN A NEW HEART AND
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN A SPIRIT.
THAT TRANSFORMS US.
AND SO CHRISTIANS BELIEVE THAT
ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND THEY PRACTICE THAT IN THEIR
FAITH.
NOT EVERYBODY PRACTICES THAT
FAITH NOBODY SAYING THAT.
ANYBODY.
IS GONNA BE FORCED TO PRACTICE.
THAT FAITH.
BUT THEY LEGITIMATELY PACKS
THAT FAITH IN THERE ARE BOOKS
THERE ARE.
CONFERENCES THERE ARE. AREAS
WHERE THERE COULD BE.
A TRANSACTION INVOLVES.
BUT ARE LEGITIMATE PRACTICES OF.
OF A FAITH. AND.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS YOU KNOW
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SAN I BELIEVE
HOMOPHOBIA IS A SIN.
I BELIEVE OSTRACIZING A GROUP
AND MALIGNING A GROUP AND
SLANDERING A GROUP.
IS A SIN.
AND SO LOOK AS AS CHRISTIANS
PRACTICING WE ARE TRYING TO.
WE ARE GOING TO STRUGGLE AGAINST
SIN AND AND WE BELIEVE.
THAT'S OUR THAT IS OUR
PERSONALLY HELD BELIEF.
THAT GOD CAN CHANGE US.
GOD I HOPE WE CAN CHAINS HAVE
HOPE BEACON CHANGES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE REFER.
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS THE MERITS OF
THE BILL OKAY.
I'M A WORK IN PROGRESS MYSELF.
AND SO LET ME JUST SAY THAT TIME
YOU KNOW I THINK WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS.
THAT THESE COULD BE MUCH BROADER
AND AND GO INTO. YOU KNOW THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL I SAID LIKE
TO WORK ON.
CERTAINLY TIGHTENING THAT TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T INFRINGE
UPON LEGITIMATE PRACTICES OF OUR
FAITH.
AND NOT JUST CHRISTIAN FAITH
BUT.
MUSLIMS AND YOU
PEOPLE OF MANY DIFFERENT FAITHS
HAVE BELIEFS THAT WE THAT WE IN
THIS BODY MAY NOT SHARE A
MAJORITY IN THIS BODY MAY NOT
SHARE BUT DO WE WANT TO START
DOWN THE PATH.
I KNOW I HAVE A COLLEAGUES IS I
HATE SLIPPERY SLOPE ARGUMENTS
BUT THERE'S A REASON WHY WE'VE
COINED THE TREE PHRASE SLIPPERY
SLOPE ARGUMENTS BECAUSE ONCE YOU
START DOWN THE PATH OTHER THINGS
COULD COME UP.
WHERE PEOPLE SAY ISN'T THIS THE
SAME JUSTIFICATION WE HAVE TO BE
AWARE OF THAT AND SO I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT WE CONSIDER? THE
LEGITIMATE EXPERIENCES OF
PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIANS FAMILY MEMBER TEN
MORE SECONDS PLEASE.
AND POTENTIALLY THE IMPLICATIONS
TO.
FREEDOM OF RELIGION AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU.
AND ON YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO THAT
AND I WOULD JUST ASK FOR THAT
GOING FORWARD.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK MEASURE UP WANTED TO JUST
FURTHER.
EXPLORE THE CONNECTION BETWEEN.
.
WHAT'S YOUR BILL DOESN'T AND
COMMERCIALIZATION PARTICULARLY
WITH RESPECT TO BOOKS AND TAPES
AND OTHER THINGS. THAT ARE
PRODUCED BY RELIGIOUS ENTITIES
WHO HAVE A POINT OF VIEW THAT
THIS KIND OF THEIR TO THERAPY IS
LEGITIMATE THAT THEY. ARE.
COUNCIL ARE IN IN IN THEIR
CHURCHES THEY PROVIDE. OF.
COMMERCIAL.
I.
TRANSACTIONS BUT THAT'S
OFTENTIMES WITH IN THE SETTING.
OF A NON COMMERCIAL A
ORGANIZATION.
I'M MEANING UP A BOOK OR A TAPE
OR.
THE OFFER OF THAT KIND OF
THERAPY IN.
THE WALLS OF THE CHURCH.
OUR WE WOULD HAVE A SOME KIND OF
A PRICE TAG TO IT TO DEFRAY
COSTS ORDER. THE OTHERWISE
HAPPY.
COULD YOU PLEASE ADDRESS THAT
DIRECTLY.
WITH RESPECT TO MOVING THIS.
POINT OF VIEW AND THIS THERAPY.
INTO A CLASS.
OF SPEECH AND COMMENTARY.
THAT IS PROHIBITED FROM BEING
COMMERCIALLY.
I UTILIZED.
THAT QUESTION TO THE TO THE
AUTHOR I'M GONNA ASK HIM TO
ADDRESS THAT IN HIS CLOTHES.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S CONSUMER
RIGHTS SECTION.
AND AS THE PROSECUTOR OF THE
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR. THAT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
DOES NOT PROHIBIT.
BANDING.
FRAUDULENT
CONDUCT.
THE FAITH COMMUNITY LIKE ANYONE
ELSE.
NEEDS TO INVOLVE.
WITH THE TIMES.
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE SUPPORT LIST
IT INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION THEM AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
SO.
THE CLAIM THAT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT CAN BE USED AS A
DEFENSE.
FOR.
PROMOTING.
FRAUDULENT CONDUCT.
IS A FALLACIOUS ARGUMENT.
I SEE NO FURTHER WRITTEN DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THEY GIVE VERY MUCH MENACE
SPEAKER I APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE AND TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE SPECIFIC. CONCERNS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY ADDRESSED.
IT THE BILL SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS
FOR ADDITIONAL THERAPIES WHICH
PROVIDE ACCEPTANCE SUPPORT
UNDERSTANDING OF CLIENTS
FACILITATION OF CLIENTS COPING.
SOCIAL SUPPORT IDENTITY
EXPLORATION AND DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING SEXUAL ORIENTATION
NEUTRAL INTERVENTIONS TO PREVENT
OR ADDRESS INDIVIDUAL CONTACT OR
UNSAFE SEXUAL PRACTICES.
IN ADDITION TO WITH RESPECT TO
THAT OF SALE BOOKS THIS IS NOT
DEFINED WITH RESPECT TO
PRACTICES.
UNDER THE BILL THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY TO SEXUAL
ORIENTATION CHANGE PRACTICES
WHICH IS CONSUMER WHICH IS BAD
OF CONVERSION THERAPY PRACTICES.
SO THE SALE.
OF THE BOOK IS NOT THE ACTUAL
PRACTICE.
MEMBERS OF I MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ASSEMBLY GIVE EXAMPLE WITH.
YOUR.
INDULGENCE MADAM SPEAKER WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
THIS ORANGE.
IF I TELL YOU.
THAT THIS ORANGE.
WE'LL HELP YOU GROW A FOOT
TALLER.
TOMORROW IF YOU READ IT.
AND I GIVE THIS TO YOU.
THAT IS OF.
YOU KNOW THAT IT WILL NOT.
HELP YOU GROW AND ADDITIONAL
FOOT.
NOW.
IF I TOLD YOU.
THIS I WANT MAKE YOU GROW
ADDITIONAL FOOT.
AND I GIVE THIS TO YOU AND ASK
YOU TO PAY ME FIFTY CENTS.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
MAKES THIS A FRAUDULENT
PRACTICE.
IF I GIVE THIS TO YOU.
THAT IS THE LEGAL.
MEMBERS WE EARLIER. THIS MONTH
PASSED A RESOLUTION WITH RESPECT
TO RECOGNIZING THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
AND I'VE I'VE I'VE SPOKEN TO
MANY OF YOU IN PARTICULAR
MEMBERS ACROSS THE AISLE. IN
WHICH THIS DOES ENJOY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW ME.
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH.
I'VE CONVERSATIONS WITH
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE AISLE AND
OF OTHER FAITHS.
THIS IS A VERY.
PERSONAL ISSUE TO ME.
NO WHICH IT RECALLS BACK IN TIME
VERY DARK TYPE.
IN WHICH GROWING UP.
IT'S SO MUCH HATE.
THAT AYE WHICH YOU WANTED TO
FIND OUT IF I COULD BE CHANGED.
IF ANYTHING COULD WORK.
BECAUSE OF THE SOCIETAL
PRESSURES THAT WE HAVE.
NOW IS WE FIND OURSELVES HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE WITH AN
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT EVERYONE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG.
WITH ME.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE CHANGED.
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
ARE YOUR BROTHERS.
ARE YOUR SISTERS.
ARE YOUR PARENTS.
OUR PASTORS.
POLICE OFFICERS.
AND EVERYONE IN BETWEEN.
WE ARE A FAMILY.
SO THIS NOTION.
THAT WE WOULD ACCEPT.
AT A PRACTICE OF THE LEGAL
PRACTICE THAT CONVERGE THERAPY
WORKS.
IS ANTI FEDERAL CALL TO MY VERY
EXISTENCE.
BODY.
AND I CAN JUST TELL YOU HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING RIGHT NOW.
IN THIS MOMENT OF VULNERABILITY.
TO WHICH THEY ARE TO TRYING TO
FIND THEMSELVES AND COME OUT.
IN A SOCIETY THAT IS VERY
HATEFUL TO THAT.
AND A MOMENT OF VULNERABILITY.
COULD I TO CHANGE.
AND FINDING OUT THAT THERE BE IN
CHARGE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
BEING TOLD THAT THEY COULD
CHANGE.
WITH NO REMEDY AND THESE
PRACTICES GO AGAINST.
THE NORM.
IT EXACERBATES DEPRESSION.
I'M MY VERY OWN SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS GOING UP TO.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES?
IS ENSURE THAT WE AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE.
AND GO WITH WHAT EVERY SINGLE.
MEDICAL GROUP.
HAS SIMILARLY STATED.
WHICH WAS THAT CONVERSION
THERAPY DOES NOT WORK.
HARMFUL.
AND IT IT IS UNNECESSARY.
AND SO COLLEAGUES AGAIN AS WE
HAD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND.
FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
THIS IS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS VERY NARROW IN
SCOPE UNDER A FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION.
SO AS WE THINK ABOUT THIS BILL
BEFORE US HERE TODAY. I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL TO DEMONSTRATE THE
COURAGE.
OF YOUR CONVICTIONS
AND UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES?
AND HOPE DEMONSTRATE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
CHERISHED.
SHOULD BE CELEBRATED.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
TO BE LOVED.
AS FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELUGU VOTES EYES FIFTEENTH
KNOWS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM NINETY AB TWENTY THREE.
TO MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE OF
THE TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
MANDATED REPORTERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER.
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
UP MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY THREE OH
TO.
A BILL THAT WILL FIX THE PROBLEM
WE HAVE IN OUR LAW THAT EXPOSES
KIDS TO FURTHER CHILD ABUSE AND
IN PARTICULAR SEXUAL ASSAULT.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO WE MET FOR
EXTRAORDINARY COURAGEOUS WOMEN I
WANT TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THEM.
JENNETTE ANSEL AND FORMER U. S.
GYMNASTICS TEAM MEMBER WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE PAN AMERICAN GAMES
AND HELP THE U. S. WON A SILVER
MEDAL.
JAMIE DOWNSHIRE FORMER U. S.
GYMNASTICS TEAM MEMBER A BRONZE
MEDALIST IN THE TWO THOUSAND
SUMMER OLYMPICS IN SYDNEY.
JORDYN WIEBER SHE WAS ONE OF THE
FEARS FIVE ALONG WITH GABBY
DOUGLAS MCKAYLA MARONEY ALY
RAISMAN KYLA ROSS WHO WON GOLD
MEDALS IN TWENTY TWELVE SUMMER
OLYMPICS IN LONDON.
AND TIFFANY THOMAS LOPEZ FORMER
SOFTBALL PLAYER FROM MICHIGAN
STATE SHE WAS A TOP TEAM
NATIONAL PROSPECT UPON HER
ARRIVAL AT MICHIGAN STATE.
EACH ONE OF THESE WOMEN WE WERE
INTRODUCED TO WHEN WE WERE ON
THE FLOOR TWO WEEKS AGO THEY
WERE UP IN THE GALLERY. AND THEY
WERE ALL VICTIMS OF DOCTOR LARRY
NASSER.
WHO?
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AND ABUSED
THEM AND DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
OTHER GIRLS ATHLETES
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES.
NOW DOCTOR NASSER IS GOING TO
JAIL.
BUT THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE ALONG
THE WAY WHO SUSPECTED.
THAT THERE WAS CHILD ABUSE OF
THESE GIRLS AND THEY DID
NOTHING.
AND THEY HAVE AN OBLIGATION
UNDER THE LAW TO THEY WERE
MANDATED REPORTERS THEY WERE
OBLIGATED WHEN THEY SUSPECTED
CHILD ABUSE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
TO LET LAW ENFORCEMENT NOW. AND
THEY DID NOTHING.
AND DINNER MICHIGAN LAW WHICH
HAS A TERRIBLE FLAW.
THEY OF THE VICTIMS HAD NO
RECOURSE.
I MET WITH THOSE FOR WOMEN THEY
ARE CALIFORNIANS.
THEY LIVE IN OUR STATE. AND THEY
LEARNS THAT BECAUSE OF THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THE
MANDATED REPORTERS.
ONLY HAD ONE YEAR IN WHICH THEY
HAD TO REPORT SUSPECTED ABUSE
AND IF THEY DIDN'T THEY WERE
FREE TO GO.
WE HAVE THE SAME FLAW IN OUR
CALIFORNIA LAW.
AND IT'S GOING TO HARM OUR KIDS
IF WE DON'T FIX IT.
THIS BILL FIXES THAT FLAW.
UNDER EXISTING LAW IF YOU'RE A
MANDATED REPORTER IN CALIFORNIA
NEW SUSPECTED CHILD IS BEING
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
YOU HAVE AND THE MOMENT THAT YOU
FIND THAT OUT AND YOU SUSPECTED
THE CLOCK BEGINS TO TECH AND YOU
HAVE ONE YEAR TO REPORT IT.
OR YOUR A AND AFTER THAT YOU'RE
NOT SUBJECT TO ANY CRIME WHICH
IS A MISDEMEANOR IN A THOUSAND
DOLLAR FINE. WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
ONE YEAR GOES BY VERY FAST IT'S
NOT A RECURRING PENALTY? AND THE
ABUSE CAN CONTINUE WELL BEYOND
THAT ONE YEAR AND THOSE KIDS ARE
NOT PROTECTED THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED IN MICHIGAN.
THIS BILL FIXES THAT BY CHANGING
THE STATURE LIMITATION START
PERIOD TO AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
FINDS OUT THERE'S BEEN CHILD
ABUSE
IT DOESN'T CHANGE TO MISDEMEANOR
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE FINE IT
DOESN'T CHANGE WHO A MANDATED
REPORTER IS. AND DOESN'T CHANGE
THE STANDARDS TO WHICH THEY ARE
COMPARED IT MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE A CONTINUING OBLIGATION TO
REPORT THE CRIME BECAUSE.
FOR THOSE GIRLS AND FOR CHILD
ABUSE VICTIMS THE ABUSE
CONTINUES.
SO MEMBERS WE ARE GONNA VISIT
LATER THIS MORNING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN PREVENT CHILD ABUSE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THE NUMBER
ONE WAYS WE CAN DO IT BY
TOUGHENING OUR LAWS WITH RESPECT
TO MANDATED REPORTERS.
AND UP MEMBERS WHEN THOSE
OLYMPIC ATHLETES THAT I MET TWO
WEEKS AGO AND I VISITED WITH
THEM AND I TOLD THEM ABOUT THIS
BILL. THEY SAID I WISHED THAT
BILL WERE LAW IN MICHIGAN I WISH
I HAD THIS PROTECTIONS I WISH
THOSE MANDATED REPORTERS NOT
ONLY. SAW STOPPED THAT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO ME AND DOZENS OF
OTHER GIRLS FOR DECADES.
BUT THAT THEY WERE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY'RE NOT.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NINETY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY TWO AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CABALLERO AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ENFORCEMENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COPIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO.
WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM PROFILING
MOTORCYCLE RIDERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE AWFUL PRACTICE OF TARGETING
INDIVIDUALS BASED ON THE
ARBITRARY FACT.
THAT THEY ARE RIDING A
MOTORCYCLE.
WEARING MODELED MOTORCYCLE
RELATED PARAPHERNALIA CONTINUES
TO BE A PROBLEM IN OUR STATE.
SPIKE CLAIMS OTHERWISE
IN FACT A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SURVEY OF CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
RIDERS CONCLUDED THAT NEARLY
HALF OF THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED.
FELT THEY HAD BEEN A VICTIM OF
PROFILING OR AN UNJUSTIFIED
TRAFFIC STOP AT LEAST ONCE.
USING PROFILING METHODS TO
ORCHESTRATE STOPS.
AND UNLAWFUL DETENTION SHOULD
NOT BE TOLERATED IN THIS SOCIETY
WHERE THE CORE PRINCIPLES OF
BOTH OUR STATE IN U. S.
CONSTITUTIONS AND ANTI
DISCRIMINATION PRACTICES ARE
VALUED AND UPHELD.
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE
OF GENERALIZED STEREOTYPES THAT
ARE BASED ON THE FACT THAT A
PERSON RIDING A MOTORCYCLE.
OUR IS WEARING CERTAIN
MOTORCYCLE CLOTHING.
CYCLISTS REPORT BEING STOPPED
AND QUESTIONED WITH THE OFFICERS
COLLECTING PERSONAL DATA SUCH AS
TAKING PICTURES OF INSIGNIA
PATCHES AND TATTOOS. ONE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM MY DISTRICT
REPORTS BEING STOPPED WHENEVER
HE RIDES HIS BIKE.
AND I HAVE A FAIRLY LARGE
VIETNAM VETERANS BIKE RIDERS
ASSOCIATION THAT REPORTS THE
SAME STOPS AND PROFILING ISSUES.
CONDUCT OR PROBABLE CAUSE NOT
APPEARANCE OR ASSOCIATION SHOULD
BE THE DETERMINANT TO INITIATE A
STOP.
NO ONE IN OUR STATE SHOULD BE
PROFILED.
WERE TREATED DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE
OF HOW THEY LOOK I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES THANK YOU OF SPEAKER MEMBERS
AS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
AND NOW. DO A TRAFFIC
ENFORCEMENT PRO MOST THIRTY
YEARS.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
THERE IS A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT.
.
THE ALLEGED PROFILING HAS
INDICATED THAT THAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO PROTECT WAS ALREADY
PROTECTED.
AND THAT THIS PROCESS HAS TAKEN
VERY SITTERS SERIOUSLY THE US
CENSUS COULD PLAY PROCESS. IS
ONE THAT ALLOWS OBJECTIVE REVIEW
OF THE FACTS.
PERCEPTION.
BY SOMEONE WHO IS PULLED OVER.
IS A VERY DIFFICULT THING TO
CONTROL.
AND I CAN JUST TELL YOU THAT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE COME TO
THIS LEVEL.
A DISCUSSION TO WHERE THE STEREO
TYPING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SEEMS TO BE OKAY.
THAT WE ARE OPPRESSORS AND THAT
WE. DO THINGS BASED ON THINGS
OTHER THAN BEHAVIOR AND I I TAKE
IT AS UNFORTUNATELY AS AN
AFFRONT.
OF THE MOOD OF MANY PEOPLE IN
THIS.
HOUSE.
AND.
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL VOTE NO ON
THIS BECAUSE IT IS VERY MUCH
UNSUPPORTABLE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUBBY OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANKS VERY MUCH I AB APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE AND ALL I CAN SAY IS
THAT. I'M ALMOST UNIVERSALLY
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT I'VE
HEARD COMPLAINTS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE UP THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A PROBLEM BUT NOT WITH
EVERYBODY BUT ENOUGH OF A
PROBLEM SO THAT THIS THIS BILL
BECOMES IMPORTANT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
SOME MEMBER CABALLERO.
MOVE MOVED ACROSS WILL MOVE THE
CALL.
ITEMS NINETY THREE NINETY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN ITEM NINETY FIVE
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY TOWARDS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THINK ABOUT IS BIGGER
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD
CLARIFY THAT A COURT WHICH
COMMITS A JUVENILE OFFENDER TO
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
STILL RETAINS JURISDICTION OVER
THAT YOUTH AND THE SUPERVISION
OF THAT YOUTH. THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES. EYES
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY SIX ACR
TWO HUNDRED MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWO HUNDRED BY SOME A
MEMBER BAKER BELT OF CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT YOU TODAY ACR TWO
HUNDRED AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
SUPPORT. WE ARE COMMEMORATING
TODAY THE MONTH OF APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH ALSO HAPPENS TO
COINCIDE ON THIS DAY WITH THE
KIDS DAY AT THE CAPITOL WHICH IS
AN EVENT HOSTED EVERY YEAR BY
THE CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
CENTER.
SPREAD THE WORD ABOUT CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION AND TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT RESOURCES FOR
FAMILIES.
ACCORDING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY CENTER FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES RESEARCH IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN ALONE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
WERE VICTIMS OF NEW BICU OF
THE ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
AND ACCORDING TO STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
TWENTY TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE
CHILDREN DIED AS A RESULT OF IT
ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
AND EACH YEAR NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
COME TO THE ATTENTION OF CHILD
WELFARE OFFICIALS THROUGH
REPORTS OF SUSPECTED ABUSE OR
NEGLECT AND ABOUT HALF OF ALL
THOSE SUBSTANTIATED CASES. ARE
CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGE OF ONE
MONTH AND FIVE YEARS OLD.
CHILDREN DESERVED TO GROW UP IN
A SAFE LOVING AND NURTURING AND
FOR A NURTURING ENVIRONMENT AND
VICTIMS OF CHILD ABUSE WHETHER
THE ABUSES PHYSICAL SEXUAL OR
EMOTIONAL OR A COMBINATION OF
THOSE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
PLACES TO LIVE.
APPROPRIATE MEDICARE APPROPRIATE
JUSTICE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE HARM
THEM AND COUNSELING OR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THESE ARE THINGS
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
MONTH HERE IN THIS BODY AND IN
OUR DISTRICTS.
IN RECENT YEARS PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE AMERICA THE CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION CENTER AND OTHER
GROUPS HAVE ORGANIZED THE BLUE
RIBBON CAMPAIGNS TO INCREASE
PUBLIC AWARENESS OF CHILD ABUSE
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY. HOW TO
PREVENT IT
AND EACH ONE OF YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE IS MEMBERS WILL HAVE ONE
OF THE?
PINS THAT IS A BLUE PEN WELL
THAT'S TO REPRESENT THE SYMBOL
OF HOW CHILDREN SHOULD HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SAFE AND
NURTURING ENVIRONMENTS AS THEY
GROW UP IN OUR STATE NEEDS TO BE
A PART OF IT.
AND THE RESOLUTION IS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO REMEMBER IT'S TIME TO
GO BACK IN OUR DISTRICTS AND
FIND WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN HELP
SUPPORT THE PREVENTION OF CHILD
ABUSE. THAT OCCURS INCLUDES THE
VOTE YOU TOOK TODAY ON
LEGISLATION TO CHANGE THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS FOR MANDATED
REPORTERS AND ALSO INCLUDES
VISITING WITH YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SEE HOW THEY ARE
ENFORCING AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT. MY
DIP MY BILLS FROM LAST TERM THAT
REQUIRES THERE IS PREVENTION
TRAINING AND PREVENTION MEASURES
IN THERE OUR CLASSROOMS AND ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. IT ALSO MEANS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE NOT ONLY PREVENTING CHILD
ABUSE WE ARE PROPERLY
PROSECUTING THOSE CASES AND
SUPPORTING VICTIMS AS THEY HELP
RECOVER. MEMBERS I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS AND YOUR SUPPORT AND I DO
ASK THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDICARE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON OFFERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY TO CO
AUTHORS ON THE MEASURE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY SEVEN ACR
TO THIRTEEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTEEN BY SEVEN NUMBER
GRAYSON AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
AUTISM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT ACR TO THIRTEEN.
WHICH ENCOURAGES FAMILIES TO
ATTEND A SENSORY FRIENDLY
SCREENING DURING APRIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AUTISM
AWARENESS MONTH.
SINCE WE FRIENDLY SCREENINGS ARE
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM AND OTHERS
TO ENJOY THEIR FAVORITE FILMS IN
A SAFE AND WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT.
PARTICIPATING THEATERS DESIGNATE
SHOW TIMES DURING WHICH SPECIAL
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE MADE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM
THESE ACCOMMODATIONS INCLUDE
LEAVING THE THEATER LIGHTS UP.
TURNING THE SOUND DOWN AND
SUSPENDING THE USUAL RULES ABOUT
MAINTAINING SILENCE
THE AUDIENCE IS FREE TO STAND UP
TALK DANCE SING WITHOUT HAVING
TO WORRY IF SOMEONE WILL
COMPLAIN OR BE DESTROYED BY
NOISE OR MOVEMENT. AND
RECOGNITION OF AUTISM AWARENESS
MONTH MY OFFICE RECENTLY HOSTED
A FRIEND A FAMILY FRIENDLY
SCREENING.
EVENT IN IN THE DISTRICT THIS
EVENT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH A
LARGE TURNOUT OF FAMILIES WHO
ENJOYED THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND
QUALITY TIME WITH THEIR LOVED
ONES AT THE MOVIE THEATER. THIS
MEASURE WILL ENCOURAGE FAMILIES
TO PARTICIPATE IN AN ENRICHING
AND ENJOYABLE EXPERIENCE A
SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
MADAM SPEAKER I ASK THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR A CO AUTHORS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON ACR TWO THIRTEEN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM OF.
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLE
OPEN FOR COAUTHORS YES PLEASE
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE ROLE. OFFERS MEMBERS THIS
ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM NINETY EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
MARK STONE AND ACTUALLY THE
CIVIL ACTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE YOUR
RECOGNIZE THEY Q. MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TAXPAYER LAWSUITS
ARE ONE OF THE PRIMARY TOOLS FOR
HOLDING JURISDICTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FRAUD WASTE
ABUSE AND OTHER BAD ACTIONS.
SUPREME COURT RECENTLY OPINED
THAT IT WASN'T CLEAR. THAT
WHETHER THIS STATUTE APPLIED TO
ALL TAXES JUST PROPERTY TAXES OR
SOME SUBSET. THEREOF AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT IS IT
ENSURES THAT ALL TAXPAYERS ARE
ABLE TO BRING SUITS AGAINST A
JURISDICTION SO I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
HOLDING. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALL
GOVERNMENTS LOCAL STATE
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE. IN
THEIR CONDUCT IN THE BUSINESS
THAT THEY DO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DEBATER
DISCUSSION MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW HE THE BOATS SIXTY
FOUR I KNOW ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
RETURNING BRIEFLY TO GUESS
INTRODUCTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAKER YOU ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
T. A TODAY UP IN THE GALLERY.
SHEILA BOXLEY PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
CENTER AND ALSO ANGELA PUT EAVIS
BUREAU. CHIEF AT THE OFFICE OF
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US TODAY THIS PLEASE GIVE A WARM
WELCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER WHAT I CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE GALLERY IF BY
GUESSES YOU TO PLEASE STAND
THERE'RE THE CONNECT FAMILY WAS
STRONG CHILDREN WHO ARE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO VISITING US. MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
WAS IN THE GALLERY.
THANK YOU MOVING BACK TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ITEM NUMBER NINETY NINE AB THREE
OH SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THOUSAND AND
SEVEN BY SOME THE NUMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
YOUR RECOGNIZE MEN SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB THREE ZERO ZERO
SEVEN HIGHLIGHTS THE NEEDS OF
VULNERABLE YOUTH POPULATIONS
THOSE WHO HAVE A PARENT.
WHO WAS CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED?
THIS MEASURE WOULD GRANT
AUTHORITY TO RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM OF SUPPORT SERVICES
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN.
INCARCERATED PARENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE.
THANK YOU SING KNOW REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEADOW QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE HUNDRED PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM OF ONE HUNDRED ONE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER MAYES AND
ACTUALLY TO PARKS AND
RECREATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES MAYES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU MEDI
SPEAKER I MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD INCREASE THE
NO BID PURCHASING AUTHORITY FOR
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY REGIONAL
PARK IN OPEN SPACE DISTRICT.
THE FIFTY THOUSAND THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE THEM IDENTICAL
PURCHASING POWER AS OTHER
DEPARTMENTS UNDER THE SAME
JURISDICTION THE INCREASE
PROVIDED BY AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN WILL COMPENSATE FOR RISING
GENERAL COSTS.
THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY RESTRICTED
THE DISTRICT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SEVENTY NO ZERO. THE MOTION
PASSES.
SORRY THE MEASURE PASSES ITEM OF
ONE O. TO PASS AND RETAIN ITEM
ONE A THREE HR ONE HUNDRED MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE HUNDRED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER QUIRK RELATIVE
TO MOSQUITO AWARENESS WEEK.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I'M OF PRESENTING
HR ONE HUNDRED ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK TO
RECOGNIZE THIS WEEK APRIL
FIFTEENTH TO THE TWENTY SECOND.
AS MOSQUITO AWARENESS WEEK
THEY YOU MIGHT WANT TO GIGGLE
ABOUT THIS BUT THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SO HOPE TO TAKE. A
LITTLE BIT OF YOUR TIME TO
LISTEN TO THIS ONE. THE BEST WAY
TO PREVENT OUTBREAKS OF WEST
NILE VIRUS AND OTHER VECTOR
BORNE DISEASES IS TO ADEQUATELY
FUND MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
DISTRICTS.
DISEASE SURVEILLANCE AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS PROGRAMS.
AND TO TH DIDN'T IN TWO HUNDRED
AND ONE ALONE. THERE WERE FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX INDIVIDUAL
CASES OF WEST VIRUS.
AND OF FORTY ONE DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE ALSO SIX
HUNDRED FORTY TRAVEL ASSOCIATED
CASES OF ZECA FEVER DETECTED
INCLUDING A HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
INFECTIONS IN. PREGNANT WOMEN
AND TEN INFANTS BORN WITH ZECA
RELATED COMPLICATIONS.
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
DISTRICT STRUCK CALIFORNIA WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE U. S.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO REDUCE
PESTICIDE RISK TO HUMAN ANIMALS
AND THE ENVIRONMENT OR WHILE
PROTECTING HEALTH.
HR ONE HUNDRED RAISES AWARENESS
TO THE WORK OF CALIFORNIA
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
AGENCIES.
TO PROTECT OUR HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AND AS WE SAY IN YOUR
COUNTY FIGHT THE BY.
NO ONE WANTS TO SPEAK ON
MOSQUITOES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE AUTHOR OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE FIRST.
HOME AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS RULE IS FOR COAL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE MOSQUITO RESOLUTION.
MADAM COURT PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY EIGHT
COOPER'S ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE AYE WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS ONE OH FOUR THROUGH ONE
ELEVEN PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM ONE TWELVE AB THIRTY TO
ELEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO ELEVEN
BY SOME THE MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SOME A BILL THIRTY TO
ELEVEN REVISES THE OPTIONAL
ORGAN DON'T KNOW DONATIONS
SECTION. AND THE STATUTORY
ADVANCED HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVE
MODEL FORM TO MATCH BEST
PRACTICES AND ENHANCE HOW WE
HONOR AN INDIVIDUAL'S CHOICE.
REGARDING ORGAN DONATION.
THESE CHANGES IN AB THIRTY TO
ELEVEN TAKE A MODEST STEP ADDING
CLARITY TO A DONOR'S CHOICE AND
MAKE THE USE OF ADVANCED
HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVES MORE
EFFECTIVE PROMOTE ORGAN
DONATIONS.
BY DOING SO THE BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE THE USE OF
THESE DIRECTORS FOR PURPOSES OF
ORGAN DONATIONS OF WHICH.
THOUSANDS REMAIN ON A WAITING
LIST FOR A LIFESAVING
TRANSPLANT.
THE ADVANCE HEALTH CARE
DIRECTIVE MODEL FORM HAS NOT
BEEN CHANGED SINCE ITS CREATION
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE YET
NATIONAL BEST PRACTICES AND
EXPERIENCE FROM OTHER STATES
REGARDING OPTIONAL ORGAN
DONATION.
CONTINUED TO IMPROVE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BUT APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES
EYES SEVENTY NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO THIRD READING.
ITEM ONE THIRTEEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN.
AS SEE ARE ONE TWENTY MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION WON
TWENTY BY SENATOR HEALTH
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
TAKING MONTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO DIG THIS RESOLUTION.
YEAH WE HAVE TO WRAP IT UP THAT
WAY SR. SCR ONE TWENTY DECLARES
APRIL IS CALIFORNIA SAFE DIGGING
MONTH.
WE JOINED MANY OTHER STATES IN
THIS DECLARATION INCLUDING
ALASKA ARIZONA GEORGIA IOWA NEW
YORK AND TEXAS.
CALLING BEFORE YOU DIG AS A
VITAL SERVICE FOR WORKERS
HOMEOWNER OF HOMEOWNERS
CONTRACTORS IN UTILITY COMPANIES
IT PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS FROM
INJURY AND PREVENTS UTILITY
DAMAGES.
THE PROCESS WORKS LIKE THIS A
PERSON PLANNING TO EXCAVATE
CALLS EIGHT ONE ONE. THEN THE
EIGHT ONE ONE SERVICE CONTACTS
IN THE UTILITY COMPANIES THAT
MAY HAVE UNDERGROUND UTILITIES
IN THE AREA. THEN THE UTILITY
MARKS THAT LOCATION OF ANY
UNDERGROUND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FINALLY THE EXCAVATOR CAN BEGIN
TO SAFELY DICK. ON A RELATED
NOTE I AM THE AUTHOR OF AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE WHICH
WILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES TO SHARE ITS
DIGITAL MAP DATA. WITH EIGHT ONE
ONE REGIONAL NOTIFICATION
CENTERS TO HELP THEM ACCURATELY
NOTIFIED THE OWNERS OF
UNDERGROUND FACILITIES ABOUT
UPCOMING EXCAVATION ACTIVITY IN
THE VICINITY I ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME TO SUPPORT SCR ONE TWENTY TO
DECLARE APRIL OF. IN CALIFORNIA
AS SAFE DIGGING MONTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK.
WOULD YOU LIKE COAUTHORS ON. ON
THE RESOLUTION.
I'M SORRY TO SENATE BILL I'M
IT'S A SENATE BILL.
OKAY MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ADEQUATE
PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM ONE FIFTEEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
WE ARE MOVING OUT TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
THE FIRST ITEM.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH AND ACTUALLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
I WILL DEFERRED THE ROUTE RE
READING OF THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT COUNTER INTO
AFTER ADJOURNMENT.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING AND HEARING
NONE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FOR THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
ASSEMBLY BONTA YOUR RECOGNIZE
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL BOTH REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
IN THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS FOR
COMING OUT LAST NIGHT. FOR OUR
SECOND ANNUAL CAPITAL CUP.
AND I COMING TOGETHER IN A
BIPARTISAN FASHION HAVING A LOT
OF FUN NOT GETTING INJURED AND
SUPPORTING SOME GOOD CAUSES YOU
EIGHT FIFTY RAISE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS LAST NIGHT FOR WE'VE
BEEN FOR THE SACRAMENTO.
FOODBANK I WANNA PARTICULARLY
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO AYE ON THE
CAPTAIN'S FOR THE REPUBLICAN
TEAM I DON'T LEADER DOLLY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT CUNNINGHAM
THANK YOU GUYS FOR ALL YOUR
SUPPORT. AND THAT THE CAPTAINS
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AYE
WERE SOME MEMBERS RUBIO SENATOR
ALLEN IT MYSELF AND IT WAS A
TIGHT GAME.
WE HAD AMAZING GOALS.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ONE THAT I KNOW IS THE SUBJECT
OF SOME CONTROVERSY HAVE BY
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
ALBERTO TRIGO AND WONDERFUL GO
BY MISTER KILEY AS WELL ALSO
SOME LATE DRAMA WITH MISTER
KILEY PUTTING A VOLLEY OFF THE
POST. AND.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM ATTENDING A
BEAUTIFUL BICYCLE KICK SAW ALL
SORTS OF FANTASTIC SOCCER BEING
PLAYED AND THE MVP OF THE GAME
WAS OUR OWN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
BERMAN WHO WAS A LITERAL CAT.
BETWEEN THE POSTS.
DIED MEAN BETWEEN THE STICKS
SAVING ALL SORTS OF SHOTS.
GREAT STUFF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND I WANT TO GIVE A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO OUR AMAZING
STAFF STARTING WITH CRYSTAL.
BUT I KNOW WHO IS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO'S OFFICE WHO.
I CAME OUT SO MANY PRACTICES PUT
IN SO MUCH TIME IN ORGANIZATION
AND AND AND AND AND THE SWEAT
BLOOD SWEAT AND TEARS TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN AND ALL OF OUR STAFF
WHO WHO PRACTICED. EYE WITH US
AND SUPPORTED US AND HELP MAKE
THE GAME HAPPENED I IT'S A GREAT
TRADITION I'M PROUD OF STARTED
IT WITH ALL OF YOU LOOK FORWARD
TO DOING IT AGAIN. NEXT YEAR SO
THANK YOU WITHOUT MORE FINE
LET'S RAISE MORE MONEY FOR
CHARITY AND I WORK MORE AND
BIPARTISAN FASHION.
AND IT'S A MEMBER RUBIO WANTS TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS AS WELL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU
AND I JUST WANNA SHOW EVERYBODY
THE TROPHY THAT WILL REMAIN AND
DEMOCRATS HANDS THIS YEAR. SO IF
YOU WOULD LIKE.
YES IF YOU WOULD LIKE IT.
TO EVENTUALLY GO TO YOU YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PRACTICE A LOT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DID
BREEDS RAISE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR CHARITY AND IT WAS A
REALLY REALLY FUN NIGHT IF YOU
DID NOT PARTICIPATE I URGE YOU
TO PARTICIPATE NEXT YEAR.
BUT I DO RECOMMEND PRACTICING
SOME OF US ARE LITTLE SORE THIS
MORNING.
BUT THANK YOU AGAIN AND YES
THANK YOU TO CHRISTOPHER AMERICA
ARE CHRIS MARINO.
SHE'S ON MY STAFF AND PUT A LOT
OF TIME INTO THE COORDINATION
AND THANK YOU AGAIN AND THINKING
TO YOURSELF FOR BEING SO. SO
WILLING TO PARTICIPATE AS WELL
THANK YOU.
pTO GREG HAYES WAS STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY WHO HELPED PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER AND REALLY
SPEARHEADED THE. THE EFFORT AND
HAS UP A FUTURE CAREER IN SPORTS
COMMENTATING IF ANY OF YOU HEARD
OF US LIKE.
THANK YOU OUT TO BE TWO IS LET'S
DO IT AGAIN NEXT YEAR THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE HAVE FURTHER BUSINESS
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
BUT AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL.
CLICK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABBIE EURO
WHAT IS YOUR PLEASURE.
ASPIRIN CAN TIME SORRY I BEG
YOUR PARDON EYES TWENTY FOUR
KNOWS TWENTY. THE MEASURE FAILS.
SOME NEVER HAVE EURO YES I COULD
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION.
YOU KNOW.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
RECONSIDERATION.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AND I ASK
ALL MEMBERS TO TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
SPEAKER RENDON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM CALL IS
NOT LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR GERMANS AND.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY IN THE JOURNAL
MEMORY OF NANCY MCFADDEN.
NANCY WAS WELL KNOWN AND WELL
RESPECTED BY EVERYONE IN THIS
CHAMBER.
SHE WAS EXECUTIVE SECRETARY AND
CHIEF OF STAFF GOVERNOR BROWN.
SHE WAS OUR COLLEAGUE AND A
FRIEND.
NANCY LANDED BIG DEALS BUT SHE
NEVER ACTED LIKE A BIG DEAL.
IF YOU READ ANY OF THE NEWS
REPORTS AND TRIBUTES THAT POURED
IN FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY YOU
KNOW NANCY STORY.
SHE WAS RAISED BY A SINGLE
MOTHER IN SAN JOSE.
SHE WAS STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT
AT SAN JOSE STATE.
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA.
O'MELVENY MYERS.
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN DOJ. AL
GORE. GRAY DAVIS.
WHERE WERE MOST OF US GOT TO
KNOW HER WAS HERE IN GOVERNOR
BROWN'S OFFICE?
MY MEMORIES THE NANCY CENTER ON
THE WORK THAT WE DID CLIMATE
CHANGE HOUSING. GUN CONTROL
TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING.
NANCY HELPED SHAPE EVERY SINGLE
MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT WE'VE
HAD IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
HERE.
SHE CHANGE LIVES THROUGH
MENTORSHIP.
SHE BETTER LIVES THROUGH
FRIENDSHIP.
AND SHE ACTUALLY SAVED LIVES
THROUGH HER LEADERSHIP.
NANCY LEAVE BEHIND HER BROTHER
BILL AND COUNTLESS FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HEARTBROKEN
BY HER LOSS.
BUT WAS SO INSPIRED BY HER LIFE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH AND YOU
EAST WING OF THE CAPITOL. I HAVE
ASKED OUR JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
CHAIR. TO ENSURE THAT INCLUDES
AN APPROPRIATE WAY AVANT'S
RYCHNOV HONORINE NANCY MCFADDEN.
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF A GREAT CALIFORNIANS.
SOME MEMBER DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THE U. HAND SPEAKER MEMBERS I.
ALSO RISE IN MEMORY OF ANSWERING
PATTON.
ONE OF THE BRIGHTEST AND MOST
WELL RESPECTED PEOPLE I'VE EVER
HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING WITH.
NANCY WAS TRUE AND DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANT. WHILE JERRY
BROWN MAY BE.
THE I HAVE THE TITLE OF THE
GOVERNOR.
EVERYONE HERE KNOWS THAT NANCY
WAS TRULY THE FORCE THAT MADE
THE OFFICE TECH.
SHE WAS ALWAYS KIND AND
PLEASANT.
AND ON A PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL SHE WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IN.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MINISTRY CREWMEMBERS I
MISSED ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS WOULD LIKE TO
STAND IN A AND ADJOURNMENT FOR
NANCY MCFADDEN. OF FOR MANY OF
US WOMEN WHO OFTENTIMES WERE. WE
LOOK AROUND THIS FLOOR AND WE
CAN SEE HIM DOUBLE.
THE AMOUNT OF WORK MEN THAT
THERE ARE WOMEN.
AND NANCY WAS THAT ONE WHO WAS
ALWAYS THERE TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
US I THINK FOR EVERY WOMAN IN
THIS CHAMBER FOR EVERYONE IN
THIS BUILDING. OF EVERYONE WHO
WORKS IN THIS INDUSTRY SHE A
PETA MICE TO WEST OF THE
STRENGTH THE INTELLIGENCE THE
HUMOR AND FOR SO MANY OF US WE
NEVER SAW HER LOSE HER COOL. IN
THE HEIGHT THAT NEGOTIATIONS SHE
HAD A SMILE IN THE HEIGHT OF THE
OF THE HARDEST TIME SHE WAS A
STEELY STRENGTH. THAT DID IT
WITH THE GENTLE GLOW OF OF HER
LEGACY WILL BE REMEMBERED BY ALL
OF US I THINK FOR ANYBODY OF US
WHO THINKS ABOUT BEING A PUBLIC
SERVICE. ANNOUNCEMENT THREATENS
FACE SHOULD APPEAR BEFORE US AND
WE ALL TRY TO FOLLOW IN HER
FOOTSTEPS IT INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO GROW
AND OUR STRENGTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I TO RISE THIS MORNING AUNT OF
THE PASSING OF NANCY MCFADDEN.
AS I'VE SAID PUBLICLY BEFORE
NANCY WAS THE DEFINITION.
CLASS.
IT CLEARLY WAS THE DEFINITION OF
THE SMARTEST PERSON IN THE ROOM.
AND IN THE END SHE WAS THE
STRONGEST OF THE STRONG.
I WON'T SAY SHE WASN'T TOUGH SHE
WAS.
ISSUES ALSO FAIR.
NANCY WAS THE QUINTESSENTIAL
CHIEF OF STAFF I WAS PREPARED TO
ADVANCE THE GOVERNOR'S POSITION.
AND NANCY DID SO WITH A WARMTH
AND HONESTY
THAT IS SORT SORELY LACKING.
IN THIS PLACE TODAY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY NANCY WAS
DIRECT AND HER WORK WAS MORE
THAN GOLD. IT WAS PLATINUM.
CALIFORNIA IS BAD BETTER BECAUSE
OF HER.
SO WOULD BE MISSED.
I THINK YOU IN RECOGNITION OF
WHAT NANCY MCFADDEN'S PASSING
MEANS TO THIS CHAMBER I WOULD
ASK ALL MEMBERS TO PLEASE RISE
FOR MOMENT OF SILENCE
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WE WILL RETURN TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY MOMENTARILY THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY APRIL TWENTIETH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
FOR A CALL IS NOW LIFTED AND WE
WILL MOVE BACK TO PREVIOUSLY A
JR ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THAT A GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF MEDINA.
YOU ARE READY ARE YOU READY FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I ASKED THE IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY.
OF MY GOOD FRIEND KATHLEEN DAILY
HOW.
KATHLEEN PASSED AWAY ON APRIL
ELEVENTH AFTER LOSING HER TENURE
BATTLE WITH CANCER.
SHE WAS SEVENTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
KATHLEEN WAS OF RIVERSIDE
RESIDENT FOR OVER SEVENTY TWO
YEARS. AND A WOMAN WHO CARED
VERY MUCH FOR HER COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS THE FOUNDER AND CEO OF
DAILY. TAX PROFESSIONALS.
I HAD THE HONOR TO SERVE WITH
KATHLEEN ON THE RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT BOARD
OF TRUSTEES.
SHE ALSO SERVED ON MANY LOCAL.
GROUPS.
LOOTING THE FOUNDING TREASURE OF
THE RIVERSIDE LINCOLN CLUB.
PRESIDENT OF THE RIVERSIDE
PHILHARMONIKER.
PRESIDENT OF THE MAGNOLIA CENTER
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER SON
WILLIAM DODDERING LA MINDY.
BROTHER ANDY AND SISTER KATHY I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO HOUSE THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MITZI SHORE KNOWN BY
MANY AS THE GODMOTHER OF COMEDY.
SURE HAD AN INDELIBLE IMPACT ON
THE COMIC WORLD BY HELPING TO
LAUNCH THE CAREERS OF MANY OF
OUR MOST FAMOUS COMEDIANS.
HER CREATING THE COMEDY STORE
WAS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS IN THE HISTORY OF STAND
UP COMEDY SAID COMEDIAN JOE
ROGAN.
SURE WAS BORN LOW INSIDE DEL IN
MICHIGAN IN NINETEEN THIRTY AND
GREW UP IN WISCONSIN ATTENDING
THE UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY.
I IT IN NINETEEN FIFTY SHE MET
SAMMY SURE A COMEDIAN AT A
SUMMER RESORT WHERE THEY BOTH
WORKED.
THE PAIR GOT MARRIED AND SPENT
SEVERAL YEARS TOURING BEFORE
SETTLING IN LA OPENING THE
COMEDY STORE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO.
MITZI SHORE TOOK OVER THE COMEDY
STORE FOLLOWING THEIR DIVORCE
TWO YEARS LATER. AND THEN
TRANSFORMED IT INTO THE
LEGENDARY VENUE INTO A LEGENDARY
VENUE. THAT SOME HAVE CALLED THE
GOLDEN AGE OF STAND UP COMEDY.
OVER THE YEARS PARTICULARLY IN
THE SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
COUNTLESS STAND UP COMEDIANS
PERFORMED AT THE STORE ENSURE
WAS CREDITED WITH HELPING LAUNCH
THE CAREERS OF MANY WELL KNOWN
COMEDIANS.
LISTEN TO THESE NAMES
RED FOX ANDY KAUFMAN ROBIN
WILLIAMS ROSEANNE BARR BOB SAGOT
GARRY SHANDLING KATHY GRIFFIN
RICHARD PRYOR JIM CARREY DAVID
LETTERMAN.
MARK MARAND TOM GREECE AND THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON AND ON AND
FOR SURE. COMEDY WAS A FAMILY
AFFAIR HER SON AULY SHORE
BECAME A COMEDIAN WITH THE WELL
KNOWN MTV SHOW IN THE NINETIES.
SURE WAS A POWERFUL GATEKEEPER
IN AN INDUSTRY DOMINATED BY MEN.
OVER HER CAREER SHE'S BEEN
DESCRIBED AS THE GODMOTHER
MATRIARCH AND QUEEN OF THE
COMEDY SCENE BUT EVEN THOSE
LOFTY TITLE SOMEHOW DON'T DO HER
JUSTICE.
SHORT SURVIVED BY HER FOUR
CHILDREN AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THINK THAT A SPEAKER OF THINK
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF LOIS LYNCH.
LOIS WAS BORN ON MARCH THIRD
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN.
AND PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY ON
MARCH TWENTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AT THE AGE OF A HUNDRED AND ONE.
WITH THEIR FAMILY BY HER SIDE.
LOIS WAS BORN IN LONG BEACH THE
EIGHT OF NINE CHILDREN.
SHE LATER MARRIED VERNE LYNCH
AND TOGETHER THE COUPLE MOVED TO
LOS ANGELES WHERE THEY HAD SIX
CHILDREN.
LOIS IN VERY ALONG WITH HER
SISTER AND BROTHER IN LAW
STARTED THE FAMILY BILLBOARD
COMPANY IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR.
AND SHORTLY THEREAFTER MOVED TO
GLENDORA.
TODAY LOIS'S CHILDREN AND GRAND
CHILDREN STILL RUN WHAT IS NOW
GENERAL OUTDOOR ADVERTISING.
IT'S PROVIDES NUMEROUS OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING SOLUTIONS FOR
ADVERTISERS THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT
AND MANY COMMITTEES THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
LOIS WAS THE HEAD OF THE ALTAR
SOCIETY AT ST DOROTHY'S CHURCH
IN GLENDORA FOR MANY YEARS.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND WERE MEMBERS
OF SQUARE DANCING CLUBS ENGLAND
DORA AND IN THE DESERT.
OR THEY FREQUENTLY TRAVEL
BETWEEN BETWEEN FOR BUSINESS AND
ISSUED A LARGE FAMILY.
LOIS IN VERNE WERE HAPPILY
MARRIED FOR FIFTY SEVEN YEARS
UNTIL HIS PASSING IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR.
AFTER HER NINETIETH BIRTHDAY
LOIS MOVED TO SUNRISE ASSISTED
LIVING IN NEARBY CLAREMONT AND
WAS PROUD AND GRATEFUL THAT
LIVED HER. ENTIRE LIFE AND WHAT
SHE REFERRED TO AS MY SUNNY
CALIFORNIA.
LOIS IS SURVIVED BY HER SIX
CHILDREN AND FIFTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN I ASK THE ASSEMBLY
TO ADJOURN TODAY IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF RUSSELL BARTON BONNER.
IT WAS WITH IMMENSE SADNESS THAT
WE LEARNED OF HIS PASSING ON
MARCH TENTH.
MISTER BONNER WAS KNOWN BACK A
BILL FOR HIS ENERGY.
TIME AND COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE.
TO BONNER OFTEN WORK WITH LOCAL
CHURCHES.
ASSISTING WITH WHAT WORSHIP
SERVICES AND MINISTERING TO THE
NEEDS OF MEMBERS.
HE ALSO DELIVERED FOOD AND
PERFORM OTHER ODD JOBS THAT NEED
TO BE DONE.
HE FREQUENTLY HELP THE INFIRM.
THE ELDERLY. AND WINDOWS BY
PROVIDING RIDES AND ASSISTING
WITH LANDSCAPING MAINTENANCE AND
HOUSEWORK.
RUSSELL BARTON BONNER WAS BORN
IN SELMA CALIFORNIA ON AUGUST
SECOND.
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM SOME HIGH
SCHOOL. IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
HE ENLISTED IN THE AIRFORCE.
HE SERVED FOR YEARS AS A RADAR
OPERATOR STATIONED ATOP MOUNT
TEMPLE PIOUS.
WHILE ATTENDING CHURCH SERVICES
HE MET ROSALIA TERRY.
WHOM HE MARRIED IN AUGUST OF
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE.
THEIR MARRIAGE OF NEARLY SIXTY
YEARS.
WAS A LOVING AND COMMITTED
PARTNERSHIP.
IT GREW TO INCLUDE THREE
CHILDREN.
ONE GRANDCHILD AND THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
FONG THEREFORE SERVICE MISTER
BONNER EMBARKED ON A CAREER IN
RETAIL MANAGEMENT. WORKING IN
TEXAS ARIZONA.
AND CALIFORNIA.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES.
RUSSELL IN ROSALIE OPEN THEIR
HOME TO THIRTEEN. FOSTER
CHILDREN.
TOGETHER THEY PROVIDED THE
FOSTER CHILDREN WITH A SOLID AND
SECURE HOME LIFE.
AFTER RETURNING TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE SEVENTIES MISTER BONNER WAS
A FREQUENT VOLUNTEERING HIS
CHILDREN'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
CLASSROOM.
HE ALSO DEVOTE HIS TIME TO FUND
RAISING FOR THE BOY SCOUTS. THE
GIRL SCOUTS INDIAN GUIDES
FOR H..
FFA.
SCHOOL CHOIRS AND BANDS.
MR BOEHNER SPENT THE LATTER PART
OF HIS CAREER WORKING AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
WOOD WE'VE REHABILITATION.
IN NORTH CORONA AND ALSO IN BACK
OF BILL.
HE RETIRED.
IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND AFTER
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS OF SERVICE.
AFTER HIS RETIREMENT IN ADDITION
TO ALL HIS COMMUNITY SERVICE.
MISTER BONNER FREQUENTLY
VOLUNTEERED HIS SERVICES IN HIS
DAUGHTER'S FIRST GRADE
CLASSROOM.
MISTER BONNER WAS A SELFLESS
SERVICE.
FIRST COMMUNITY.
LOVE IS COMMUNITY.
AND HIS MEMORY WILL LIVE LONG IN
OUR HEARTS.
I'M SPEAKER I WISH I REQUEST WE
JOURNEY MEMORY TODAY.
IN HONOR OF MR BOEHNER.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES TO THE DESK.
HOPE.
MR FRAZIER DO YOU HAVE GUESTS
MIKE OUR THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE TWO OF
MY COLLEAGUES THE BAR FAMILY.
UP IN THE GALLERY.
HERE TO HONOR THEIR FATHER AND
HUSBAND AND.
AND.
.
UNBELIEVABLE MAN IN THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING WITH US.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MEMBERS OF PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL OF REQUEST TO
ATTORNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER COOLEY MOVES AND MR
ACOSTA SECONDS AT THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
APRIL TWENTY THIRD AT ONE PM
.
A BOAT CHANGE.
GARCIA.
AB TWO NINE SEVEN TWO. FROM AYE
TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO ICE NOT
VOTING.
BIGELOW FILE NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE.
FROM AYE TO NO.
AB TWO ZERO ZERO ONE.
FILE ORDER EIGHTY THREE.
AS THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE
I TO KNOW.
OKAY.
BEAU CHANGE.
ACOSTA.
AB TWO ZERO ZERO ONE FROM AYE TO
NO.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COSTA.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE I TO KNOW
.
WHEN I MOVED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR READING.
MARGUERITE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN.
I SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE SOME
LEGAL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NOT SOME
EVIL SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE AYE
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE ASSEMBLY
WILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE EYES
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN FOURTEEN.
I SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NOT
ASSIGNABLE TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE
SOME REAL TWENTY THREE HUNDRED.
AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE EXILE
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN.
EYES SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE A
SINGLE TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE.
ISA SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE THE
FINAL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX
WITH URGENCY. AYE. AYE SIXTY
EIGHT ON THE URGENCY KNOWS NONE.
AND ON THE BILL AYE SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS NOT.
SOME WILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE ISA SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE
SOME REAL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FOUR.
AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE SOME
ABLE TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN I
S. SIXTY A KNOWS NONE SIMILARLY
BY SIXTY ONE. ISA SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS NONE A SINGLE TWENTY SIX.
THE ISIS SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE
A SINGLE TWENTY SEVEN OH FIVE.
ISAIAH SIXTY EIGHT. KNOWS NONE A
SIMILAR TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY TWO.
EYES SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE AS I
WILL THIRTY SEVENTEEN. ISA SIXTY
EIGHT KNOWS NONE ASSEMBLY WILL
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY AYE SIXTY A
KNOWS NONE HAS ENABLED TWENTY
FORTY NINE. ISA SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS NONE ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
ISA SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SIXTEEN.
I SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS NONE